Flugreisen werden oft als das schlimmste ökologische
Verbrechen überhaupt bezeichnet.
Denn die Folgen für Umwelt und Klima sind
verheerend.
Und so wird weltweit fleißig an ökologischem
und günstigem Treibstoff für Flugzeuge geforscht.
Einem chinesischen Forschungsteam ist jetzt
vielleicht der Durchbruch gelungen.
Sie haben nämlich aus Pflanzenabfällen Bio-Flugzeugbenzin
entwickelt, das eine höhere Energiedichte
als Kerosin hat.
Somit soll es tatsächlich konkurrenzfähig
zum herkömmlichen Hochleistungs-Treibstoff
sein soll.
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Sciencevideos abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts, Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Daran gibt es nichts zu rütteln: Kerosin
als fossiler Brennstoff ist alles andere als
umwelt- und klimafreundlich.
Deswegen gibt es Überlegungen, auch in der
Luftfahrt auf Elektroantrieb umzurüsten.
Eine andere umweltschonende Alternative zum
fossilen Kraftstoff könnten Biokraftstoffe
sein.
Schon jetzt testen einige Airlines Biokerosin
und mischen ihn zum gewöhnlichen Sprit hinzu.
Solche sogenannten Drop-In-Fuels erzeugen
bei ihrem Verbrennen zwar auch Treibhausgase.
Doch ihre Nettobilanz könnte CO2-neutral
sein, wenn sie aus pflanzlichem Material hergestellt
werden.
Das Problem: Das Biokerosin ist fast dreimal
teurer als das normale und ist daher alles
andere als wirtschaftlich.
Das Ziel vieler Forschungsteams weltweit ist
es, Bio-Flugzeugbenzin zu produzieren, das
eine höhere Energiedichte hat als gewöhnliches
Kerosin.
Denn so könnte es dann auch wirtschaftlich
lohnend sein.
Dazu der chinesische Physiker Ning Li: “Der
Einsatz von hochdichtem Flugzeugkraftstoff
kann die Reichweite und Nutzlast eines Flugzeugs
erheblich erhöhen, ohne dass dafür größere
Tanks benötigt werden.
Bisher allerdings fehlt ein Syntheseweg für
diese Polycycloalkane aus Zellulose.“.
Als Ausgangsbasis für das Bio-Flugbenzin
diesen neu entwickelten Syntheseweg könnten
Pflanzenabfälle wie Stroh, Mais-Stängel
oder Sägemehl dienen.
Ziel der chinesischen Physiker war es, diese
in das Gemisch aus ringförmigen Kohlenwasserstoffen
umzuwandeln, das für Kraftstoffe typisch
ist.
Dafür haben die Fachleute in einem ersten
Schritt die Zellulose aus den Pflanzenresten
herausgelöst.
Mit der organisch chemischen Verbindung namens
“Dichlormethan” haben sie die Zellulose
dann in die chemische Verbindung namens 2,5-Hexanedion
umgewandelt.
Das funktioniert bei normaler Temperatur und
normalen Druck.
Das 2,5 Hexanedion wird dann mehrmals mit
Wasserstoff zusammengebracht und reagiert
so zu längeren Ketten aus ringförmigen Kohlenwasserstoffen.
Laut dem Bericht der Fachleute konnten sie
durch diesen Syntheseweg eine mehr als 70-prozentige
Ausbeute des Kohlenwasserstoffs erreichen.
Letztendlich bringen Katalysatoren den Syntheseweg
dann zu Ende und Polycycloalkane mit zwölf
und 18 Kohlenstoffatomen entstehen.
Laut der beteiligten Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler ist dieses Ergebnis eine
Premiere: “Unseres Wissens nach ist dies
der erste Bericht über die Synthese von Polycycloalkanen
aus 2,5-Hexanedion und Wasserstoff”.
Entstanden ist also ein Kohlenwasserstoff-Gemisch,
das zum einen als hochdichter Flugzeug-Kraftstoff
verwendet werden kann.
Aber nicht nur das.
Zudem kann das Gemisch laut der Experten und
Expertinnen auch zu herkömmlichen Kerosin
dazugegeben werden und damit Umweltbilanz
und Energiedichte verbessern.
Dazu das Fazit von Li: „Unser Biokraftstoff
kann die CO2-Emissionen der Luftfahrt senken,
weil er aus Biomasse entsteht und eine höhere
Energiedichte als konventionelles Kerosin
besitzt“.
Das Besondere an diesem Syntheseweg ist, dass
nicht nur die Ausgangsstoffe günstig sind,
sondern auch die Produktion an sich.
Bedingt dadurch, dass nur wenige Reaktionsschritte
nötig sind, können die Energiekosten minimal
gehalten werden.
Somit ist der Biokraftstoff für Flugzeuge
laut der Fachleute eindeutig konkurrenzfähig
zu gewöhnlichem Hochleistungs-Treibstoff.
Und somit auch wirtschaftlich lohnend.
Dennoch gibt es noch eine große Herausforderung.
Denn bei dem für die Synthese notwendigen
Dichlormethan handelt es sich um ein giftiges
und umweltschädliches Lösungsmittel.
Und so muss das Forschungsteam dringend nach
einer Alternative suchen, die in der Lage
ist, die Zellulose effektiv umzuwandeln.
Somit fehlt uns also weiterhin eine ökologisch
und wirtschaftlich überzeugende Alternative
zu Kerosin aus fossilen Brennstoffen.
Aber der Weg ist jetzt klar.
Jetzt muss also dringend weiter geforscht
werden.
Denn die CO2-Emissionen des Luftverkehrs tragen
schon jetzt zur globalen Erwärmung mit etwa
fünf Prozent hinzu.
Was das Ganze nicht besser macht: Fachleute
prognostizieren ein jährliches Wachstum des
Luftverkehrs von etwa vier Prozent.
Elektrisches Fliegen vor dem Start!
Draufklicken.
Anschauen und Clixoom abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!